- My field is high-energy
theoretical physics.
(overlapping speech)
- [Narrator] The language
of science can be
a bit difficult to understand.
But the reason science
is hard to listen to
is because it's hard to communicate.
Just ask Natalie, a climate scientist
who teaches at George Mason University.
- Often with my class, I have
the students' attention
for only a few minutes,
so it becomes very
important for me to think,
"How can I become a more
effective communicator?"
- [Narrator] That's where
actor Alan Alda comes in.
He runs an organization that
helps scientists like Natalie
clearly communicate their field of study,
and they do it using improv comedy.
- I wondered, if I worked with scientists
on learning to do some of the
basic exercises of improv,
I could get this connection established
between scientists and their audience.
So I thought, "Let me try it."
- I'm Terry.
(hums)
And this is Jen.
(laughter)
- [Alan Alda] We established
a program to start
with basic improv exercises so that
scientists can communicate better.
- I'm Melanie, and this is Sarah.
- We train a really wide range of people.
People from NASA, people
from the Parks Department,
physicians and medical researchers.
We do a lot of physicalization of emotion
and thoughts in these exercises.
The main thing for me is that they
help you connect to another person.
- Scientists, were you able
to explain your science?
- Sort of.
- [Narrator] Natalie took the workshop
to help teach her class.
Since then, she's been able to connect
with her students in a new way.
- The number one thing that
I've started doing differently
since the workshop is thinking,
"Would I have known this word
"when I was a first-year
university student?
"Would I have been as
comfortable with this concept?"
And, as a result, that
makes me empathize more
and clearly articulate the concepts
and the step-by-step process.
So what would happen to this
molecule at zero kelvin?
So when I look out at my class
and I emphasize that message,
that everything they're
learning along the way
is so that they can have an understanding
of how climate change actually works,
and they can communicate that.
(upbeat music)
(cheering and applause)
- [Narrator] Since they
began, the center has had
over 14,000 people go
through the workshops.
- I think good communication
is very important,
not just about science and
not just about medicine,
but good communication
makes the wheels turn.
We need it in every activity of our lives.
So your message is built
on the idea of connection and relating,
which I think is one of
the most important things
we can do for one another.
(dramatic music)